yeah welcome to new video I'll be doing
some three minutes games on nice you see
again let's see what happens i already
have the request pending here to get a
three minute game game started alright
so here we go yeah going for you six b6
quit altered somewhat tricky for c4
players okay we transpose into some sort
of limbs old Dutch candle set up yeah
often you should be forms the way to go
in those positions making sure that oops
that white never gets to play d 5 under
favorable circumstances
yeah pretty normal solid position here I
have various ideas I can play for e 5
later or I could play for something like
a 6b five to undermine the c-4 born I
tried this plan it's often interesting
to see pawn moves that I have when I
define for example so it goes a form
yeah I came so that this mud encouraged
me to play a five so that after be five
now Queenie 7i fc5 prevented I hope at
least I have this prevented um okay i
can try 45 now should i prepare this
with rook e8 maybe or the other work
hard to tell in this position what route
you should take they are not so sure if
i take the a rookie my place see five so
maybe better this one ok seems to try to
prepare to see five minute ok let's play
five now and what now should i capture
twice with the piece maybe the Sun might
be interesting ok I now see that Bishop
Defoe cannot take on g tool by the way
yeah i think i can and then take only
five this look sir looks bit more
pitiable healthier so now it's got a
frozen queen side and I'm Bishop g4 I
can grab you too so
so it would be an extra foam
okay so should I try at I try this g5g
phone maybe I'm getting securing a piece
on only form the night which was why i
dim okay it takes this off good but just
preventing this yeah it's difficult now
to do to do something in all time four
days of a wide of course yeah you just
grab this also very quickly okay
yeah maybe he's right I didn't really
think about taking on edge form it looks
really bad at first but he's got a ch3
now maybe all this move would be form
before to come okay not much that that I
can do
now have some counter play on the edge
poet so the closer looks bad check
yeah can I do
so so it's difficult for me to and
belief that he took this instantly on
edge for bed okay it was a good move
check check check yeah I don't have much
choice in spending lots of time on all
those checks so don't really amount to
much try to get some can't play let's
sound difficult though and now I'm
perfectly okay again the a porn should
decide
check check check check white forfeits
on time yeah I don't know what you did
in this end game it was just lost for me
and yeah this age for move was just
silly he could just take it off and my
rook says so i just thought i would get
it back anyway but it so that's not the
case if I don't play this there's not
much not much going on really alright
next game at the end I was just lucky he
played this game started really
strangely okay so let's play some before
here willow pass yeah at least I've got
some experience about the Sun on the
black side an entire marshal here so um
what what's going on the etic just those
some small mu CLC three maybe a four
also i don't know mr. looks looks fairly
normal
try to get some play on the kingside
pressure rising hear this h6 pawn
alright you felt provoke to take this so
I've at least them have two bishops but
of course black is some is very solid
I'd like to open up the H file now g3
kingi Tokyo gauge one stuff like this
I'm okay this I can take end okay
thought age six would be but i can i can
play am I can play Queen move here
threatening g5 yeah he needs to play a
something like this to prevent it how
would I continue now unfortunately i
don't have fun ever look and I it's a
light and work with every work of course
I don't have a light to to put on f5 I
think I should play g3 at some point
okay I want to clear this for g3 so that
the night on f4 yeah that he cannot get
to a forward this night yeah well I
don't mind that I was thinking about
getting the rukon loan on f3 anyway rook
f3 at five stuff like this and now I
even gave me a temple for this of course
the bishop be lost on this diagonal and
the way to f7 yeah this was what I had
in mind
so just for treating you okay young and
this truck should be nice really this
configuration yeah so that I can take
off the slide if you place 96 now I
grabbed the seafoam he cannot post
because of 70 m it's very nice setup
here f7 is rather weak I could have
taken it actually didn't appreciate this
this alright so let's um use the C file
now
now I can get back the rope here time
warning yeah nice defense here he
somehow kept his position alive I want
to exchange much more here but this Rick
cannot go to the sea fowl which is bad
really
just grab grab the material here he
wanted to get some activity she's very
understandable so I sect pawns
so give this check here to to to to draw
the look back this should should win
enough material to to win the game check
check check black resigns yeah this look
pretty neat i think i probably am miss
plated slightly when i will add this
dominating position this here i need to
somehow of course I can take f7 but they
need to play some more that I keep the
c4 okay but I think I'll slow nice okay
next game started neither three not sure
yet what I am going to play ok I'll
transpose back to a Queens gambit here
play the Shattuck over here can you
place the the old main line some bit out
of fashion but of course quite them
quite solid for white
okay I'm not quite sure what there
should be five is doing so I guess c4
he'll play be three
not sure okay I'll play the normal move
first maybe c4 was some possibility
okay i wonder i really want to see now
what what he's doing after see for this
the silly bishop would no no square
where does it go yeah sure i can do
stuff like this battalion just be two
hanging else and so on is the Sun
problem Quincy five also dad en route
see five all kinds of pinning moves here
oopsie oopsie five you might have queen
before might be really silly okay so and
let's just grab the bleep on yeah of
course it's not entirely clear here but
would be one I have Queen a three and
he's still in sort of a pena with the
bishop I don't see how he untangles this
threatening larne lough yet we should be
safe let's not a threat yet can capture
d5 this is why I'm wrap this but now I'm
just threatening now i will threatening
knight c6 okay if I take a for now he
grabbed some he grabbed c6 and wince
look so I cannot do that time morning
let's just drop back it's an extra point
after all so what now maybe intending
for here
hmm
we are a bit too slow yeah I spent too
much time sort of making sense office
with moose and well it didn't really
need to anything good
yeah of course the position is no
problem but then the time is
yeah he's got the second-ranked wide
open so this should at least be a draw
position wise just a draw check check
draw object Gras offered come on Ron
alright so on at least a draw I think
I'm this this is just them cannot be
cannot be good for wise there should be
just clearly better with the right move
yeah 97 the computer want students to
play yeah queen bee center of the idea I
was irritated by queen bee seven but
maybe it's not such a big deal alright
started the next game let's play before
again it worked before and got a modern
defense sort of set up yeah this is a
very solid set up for I'd be fine would
be a typical mb5 would be an completely
yeah it didn't do it completely anti
positional this however some fairly okay
for black so the structure are really
close to a ruler passier Saudi five now
yeah I is it taking you for no really so
let's close the center I've got my
pieces positioned in a way that you can
hardly play I have five at any time I
mean it's almost impossible to prepare
so yeah I expected this that you would
play on the coincide
so on probably yeah let's see what is
doing now yeah this move I'm not sure
really damn it also weakens the b5
square quite severely but try to reroute
the light quickly to see 3 yeah and now
we're thinking of just taking and Bishop
d3 getting a grip on the light squares
you can place you Father okay let's
let's prepare the specialty three moves
should be hard for him to not have a
disadvantage on the queenside really
yeah you can take it tonight f4 okay
doesn't so regroup here yeah he wants to
go Quinn g5 obviously
hmm that's might be dangerous
yeah it looks very nice on the queenside
but it doesn't have to happen if i mated
but um the moment I would still say that
damn he doesn't have anything directly i
also have possible possible rookie three
move ya need to put ignores pressure on
d6 here this is the the point of attack
so yeah if i take on d60 text e6 and at
the end I've got a meeting problem time
Barney okay I need you attack the night
I think need to get rid of this piece
and I can just take a five also next
move he still doesn't have a real attack
going at least I don't see it
hmm
this position that looks a bit shaky
here must admit
d5
I want to get to get to the slide it's a
matter of fun time now also yeah that
the position yeah really yeah of course
this was completely winning for me this
position we form is just a strategical
rag for black white is playing this
soldier so badly maybe have some drawing
chances just a groaner check gain drawn
very lucky at least at the end yeah I
think I did this this kind of position
somewhat later around here I'll think
I'm just winning only need to play it
precisely or let's see here the other
computers only on +1 sizes got some play
so yeah here it gets messy the position
is not good what coordinated here rook
takes f 2 acre of plate this is wins
instantly okay look after we have two
queens III takes on f2 when it's over
yeah it looked shaky and let it look
checking all right so next one gain
started okay let's play French for a
change
yeah tried all kinds of nausea back when
I played the French also this one idea
being that it is used for MUFON would
see five but you want to delay it one
move so yeah this should be should be
okay this is surprising okay
yeah it just trees my bishop you can try
a staff like rookie one we should be 695
but I'm willing to risk this okay it's
not interested in all this you just
wants to exchange this bishop um hmm
well if I play d4 his son still got this
Bishop b5 trick all right so this is not
the way to go should I let him take on
now will be should be eight is just just
bogus okay let's take it
yeah I've got the isolator pond but
that's not the end of the world
yeah I'm not really threatening the
light because of Bishop h7 just want to
tickle the beep or NAB it end continue
rupee aid and so on is just a move to
connect the works
it's so not a problem really just play
b6 stay solid it's a in general hard to
to windows kind of isolated pawn
positions so the same kind of line is
not so great if you really need a win
okay not quite sure what done what's the
point of this move time morning am NOT
anything could also take it
yeah white what simply has nothing maybe
it's just playing on time from one
possible
want to go 96 check check
yeah if it takes I take with on the mud
and be three years week I'll just grab
be three next move alright so let's push
the pawn yeah I really spot the sand
game it was really not much happening at
first so let's push right now get light
for orphans on time yeah really gifted
this end game away it was well George
just the isolated pawn doesn't really
help want to to get much alright so the
next one but it's hard to win usually
but possible if you just get get gifted
this like a just a pawn for nothing
all right waiting for new game it takes
a while game started okay well before
really worked well so okay I'll play I
play the Smith Moria okay declined so
into a c3 Cecilia yeah this line is
actually really bad for black but um
probably I won't manage to refute it I
think that this is right but how does it
continue probably this one yeah he seems
to know what is what is doing they're
playing almost instantly I'm just
guessing here I mean this line is really
completely unplayable yeah that's it's
just uh it's just just just terribly bad
but it doesn't help if you don't know
how to refute it maybe Bishop e3 here
yeah clock so what's this material wise
it's equal could be worse so should I
just drop drop this back now or maybe in
yeah maybe securing a post hole for the
night as an idea
got 97 threatening so you cannot grab
III
okay so still be threatening III yeah I
don't don't mind this and what I want to
do is try to get the B porn if possible
okay let's let secure this snow young
position should be okay I'm just down on
time as usual yeah but we can really
refute this opening it's not no player
the only thing that I know about this is
Sir having a brief glimpse at this myth
maroc gambit book by Mark esselman but
looking at it 4minute doesn't mean you
know the opening he also had this of
course in the book also declined Maura
so on okay maybe he's going for 4g form
object prevent that for a move at least
now I'm get this this moving
check time morning oops job looks a bit
shaky this position and you can force it
wrong with 92 still would be surprised
if you would do it you can try to fight
as black cha ok he wants to go see a do
95 smile gem Brooksie 895 I can take
first this is this is stupid and then
root CA yeah very silly okay I'll slip
maybe have something with the a porn can
can try yeah I really hate that someone
you place an opening that should that
should that just just lose this if I
would could know it and yeah well what
can you do check check check
I know he's having quite some some
problems here with converting us
advantage check check no I'm Jack come
on suddenly lose check check check oops
black forfeits on time hey you for not
time oh this this was a weird game what
the heck was he doing is if she was just
pre moving here yeah pre-move probably
that was just panicking hear that that
that I get get rid of the porn so but
don't even want this yeah very a very
good game i want to check quickly if
there's a name in there no it's a dutch
international master it could be that i
know him alright so let's let's keep
this game as the the finishing the
finishing one it was quite entertaining
yeah thanks for watching talk to you
soon with new videos